Speaker 1: Donald Trump is a billionaire, I guess,
and he is begging for money in a dark room with
terrible lighting, looking as dark orange
as we have ever seen this guy. Donald Trump,
on the eve of his arraignment, an arrest and
surrender and fingerprinting and mugshot.
Recorded a video in a very dark room where he is
issuing another plea for cash. He says he needs
you to contribute. Now, I have to say, it's
not really clear what you're contributing to.
Are you contributing to Trump's campaign? Are you
contributing to Trump's legal defense fund? What
is he asking you for? Money for doing the darkest
we have seen? Trump Literally and figuratively.
Speaker 5: If you're doing well, because all of
the things that I've done have brought you wealth
and prosperity, or at least you're extremely
comfortable. It would be really great if you could
contribute to our campaign. You know how to do it.
Speaker 1: So it's a campaign
contribution he wants.
Speaker 5: No president in the
history of our country has been subjected to such
vicious and disgusting attacks. Really. But they
only attack me because I fight for you. It's very
simple. They can't buy me. They can't control me.
And that scares them beyond belief. Hmm.
Speaker 1: Doesn't really make sense
when you look at the polling, but. Okay.
Speaker 5: Since the very beginning, I've
shunned the global is special interest Donors made
a fortune off of destroying our country. Instead,
our presidential campaign has always been funded
by grassroots patriots like you. Your contribution
today will show the left that nothing can destroy
the greatest political movement in history. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there are people donating to Trump.
We looked at some of that fundraising data,
and indeed, Trump raised a pretty penny after
the indictment was announced. But isn't he a
billionaire? Like what? Why does Trump need
to raise money? Why does a multibillionaire
need people's money? It doesn't really make
sense unless you understand that Trump sees
his followers as marks in an ongoing con. Now,
the fact that Trump is raising money off of this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's good or bad
for Trump. As I've said before, it does seem
that Trump's followers are being energized by the
indictment, and indeed the indictment might help
Trump in the 2024 Republican primary. I don't
see how the indictment gets Trump even a single
vote in a general election. The very same chaotic
surroundings that followed Trump everywhere, which
hurt him in 2020, are going to hurt him in 2024.
And an indictment is absolutely chaotic. Now.
Trump is trying to fundraise off of this. There's
a good, nice, concise CNBC article. Trump campaign
uses newly restored Facebook page to fundraise
off of the indictment. They have the official
election defense fund with $1,000 match, which,
of course, we never know if it's real or if it's
not. The copy was as follows The radical left, the
enemy of the hard working men and women of this
country have indicted me in a disgusting witch
hunt. Please make a contribution of $47 or more
by 11:59 p.m. to help defend our movement from
the never ending witch hunts during these dark
times and will send you your very own. I stand
with President Trump T-shirt for free, which,
as we know, that could become a collectible item.
I wish I had stocked up on the Trump knives, by
the way, before he was indicted. I'm sure they've
just skyrocketed in value. So realistically,
the grift simply continues. This has been
a grift for a very long time, and it's not
going to stop when with the indictment it
wouldn't if Trump somehow ended up in jail,
which is not going to happen. I think the grift
would continue from there. And we are going to be
watching the next 48 hours very, very closely. Is
there a gag order? Does the fundraising continue?
Do Trump's protesters actually come out and
seem even remotely interested in defending him,
or is it just a couple dozen people at Mar a
Lago? All of it will be live on our YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook. And it is
going to be quite a couple of days.